most people vote on issues that are more  tangible and more visible such as the  economy and even cnn lib state media is  admitting that the economy is in  shambles where do we stand right now  with inflation well i think for a lot of  americans their reality is being shaped  by the really high inflation let's take  a look at cpi consumer inflation you'd  have to go back to the early 80s to see  the type of levels we're seeing the last  cpi report came in at about eight point  six percent of course we know under the  hood of that number it's really high  energy prices really high food prices uh  the cost of new and used cars have gone  up pretty much everything broad-based  has gone up  even the chiron on the screen it says 88  say us is on the wrong track that's cnn  cnn is changing its tune because no  matter how left-wing the people who run  the network are they want to make money  and hold on to the handful of viewers  that they have left they don't want to  go down with joe biden